welcome to metaphysical milkshake i am
your host reza aslan and i am the other
host rayne wilson you know rayne i gotta
i gotta say this it's been something on
my mind uh lately i i i need your two
cents please yeah tell me talk to me
babe i'm curious what do we owe each
other uh are you talking about venmo i
thought i sent you that money for dinner
from last week what are you talking
about no no no i mean yes yes i am
talking about the money you owe me but
but i'm talking about like deeper than
that like what do we owe
each other you know what i'm saying oh
no i get it i get it you're going deeper
you're getting you're getting i see what
you're getting at you're you're still
upset that i spilled that grape juice on
your new rug
and uh i apologize for that already we
googled it baking soda is going to get
it out i've also sworn off drinking
grape juice what is a
man in his mid-50s doing drinking grapes
anyway what is a man in his 50s first of
all it wasn't a new rug it was a persian
rug it was a an heirloom it was passed
down generations so clearly i'm solo
said of that but i'm not even talking
about that i'm talking about like
morally speaking morally speaking what
do we owe each other it's more out the
morality of rug stains like
okay look let me put it as simple as
possible okay let's imagine that we're
having dinner okay we're and and i start
choking
on the food it's at your house
and the only way
you could save my life was by rushing
over me but in doing so the grape juice
in your hand will spill not on my
priceless persian rug but on your
rug
would you save my life if it meant
ruining your rug
that's a really really really nice rug
it's a really nice rug i would save your
life because i'm rich and i can just buy
another rug i would just buy a rug made
out of solid gold
all right okay i i forgot about that
part uh okay but what if i told you that
instead of
dropping a rack on a new rug you could
instead donate the rug money to a
charity and save a child well that would
that would be a nice thing to do yeah
definitely
are you saying i shouldn't buy any more
rugs okay you're not you're getting
closer you're getting closer okay
what i'm trying to say is that
every day all of us you know we make
these wasteful choices we buy like a
plastic water bottle
when we have tap water at home which is
just as fine you know we splurge on
things that we don't need so if you
really think about it those things
really start to add up yeah got it so
you're saying that
a human life
is
worth
more than material things
bingo my friend welcome to metaphysical
milkshake the show where we go deep we
get weird and we search for the meaning
of life along the way presented by cast
media and soul pancake
[Music]
we actually have somebody here who can
help us
navigate this incredibly complex
topic the one the only
peter singer peter is here to talk to us
about utilitarianism about effective
altruism
about the idea that you know we should
maximize in all of our actions the
well-being of others peter singer that
the uh drowning child analogy guy yes he
did not drown a child
but yes the
drowning child
analogy guy folks we've got some fun
facts of peter singer peter singer
believes in utilitarianism
our choices should be guided by an
effort to maximize happiness he's got an
organization pretty amazing with a great
website the life you can save
and which also recommends a selection of
charities deemed by charity evaluators
such as givewell
to be the most effective when it comes
to helping those in extreme poverty he's
also an animal rights advocate uh became
a vegetarian in his mid-20s and uh as he
after he learned about the brutality of
factory farms
and we're going to get to his famous
drowning child analogy one of the great
analogies of the modern world very
excited to speak to him
but before
we welcome him on the show let's talk
about this giveaway reza special deal
for our listeners folks and this isn't
even a thing that you need like a
hashtag metaphysical milkshake to but
because he's peter singer and because
this is how he rolls
the first 20 people
who rate
and or review us on apple podcasts all
you gotta do is send a screenshot of
that to metaphysical
cast media.com metaphysical at k-a-s-t
m-e-d-i-a castmedia.com the first 20
people will get a free copy
of the life you can save the book that
we want to begin
talking to our guest peter singer about
also folks metaphysical listeners can
also download the audiobook for free
what
everyone there is a link in the show
notes
download the audiobook for free
uh it's fantastic the entire book has
been read
by a chimpanzee it's what it's wonderful
he's very big into animal rights and he
wants to see animals more involved in
podcasting
uh welcome to the show dr peter singer
i'm very happy to be with you you know
this formative book the life you can
save originally came out i guess in 2009
and uh this is the 10th anniversary
edition i feel like everybody i know has
read this book at one point or another
and i'm so glad for the reissue it's so
i mean obviously you've been
at the forefront of
animal rights uh you know moral
questions of effective altruism you know
for
decades but this book i think was you
know formative in
uh putting a lot of these ideas and
theories into the public space it's
become so much a part of like the way
that we talk about ideas of altruism and
and giving um and of course very
famously there's an analogy that this
that launches this book an analogy that
i'm sure you have said i don't know a
couple of million times at this point
uh but for those few people in our
listening uh audience who may not be
familiar with the analogy of the
drowning child would you mind just for
the one millionth and one time
uh presenting that analogy and then sort
of give us an idea as to
what we're supposed to understand about
this analogy sure
so i'll ask you to imagine that you're
walking across a park one day and
you know the park well it has a pond in
it you know that the pond is quite
shallow because
in summer you see kid sometimes playing
in it and a teenager can just waist deep
uh but it's not summer now so you don't
expect to see anybody in the pond but as
you look at it you notice that there is
something in the ponds thrashing around
and when you look more closely it's a
small child just a toddler who can't
stand
so your first reaction is well this
toddler seems to be drowning you know
who's looking after the toddler where
are the parents or a babysitter
but you look around you don't see
anyone at all
so then you
think um
maybe i better rush into the pond jump
into the pond and save the child it's no
danger to me because i know it's a
shallow pond
and i could easily do that
but then you have a less noble thought
which is that you've put on some of your
most expensive
favorite clothes and shoes because
you're going somewhere important and
they're probably going to get ruined if
you jump into this muddy pond
so
you ask yourself
oh it's not my child and nobody asked me
to look after this child
do i really you know do i really have to
go and save the child or should i just
forget that i ever saw the child
and go on my way
now i hope that you listeners out there
thinking about that will think yourself
oh no you couldn't just ignore the child
because you don't want to ruin your nice
clothes
uh
it would be a monstrous thing do you
certainly should jump into the pond and
i would jump into the pond if i were in
that situation and save the child
good so i hope you do all react that way
but but the point of the analogy is to
say
there are children who are dying who we
can help
we can perhaps save their lives for not
much more than you would have to pay to
replace those expensive clothes you had
on
and
yet most of us are not doing it most of
us are not sending money to the against
malaria foundation to provide bed nets
so that children won't die of malaria in
malaria-prone regions
or they're not providing other basic
health fixes to save lives to restore
sight in people who are blind just
because they have cataracts
to do other
operations surgery that can
really restore a life to somebody who's
got a
an obstetric fistula which is a terrible
situation that can ruin their life and
we can do this for for
these sorts of costs that we can easily
afford so if we know this
and we're not doing anything
to support these
excellent organizations that are
effectively helping people and saving
lives elsewhere in the world
how are we different from the person who
doesn't jump into the pond because they
don't want to ruin their clothes and is
is the fact that these people are
further from us a morally crucial
difference
i don't see how
that distance can really
be morally decisive
especially if you know that there are
these effective independently checked
organizations that are really going to
use your donation in in a way that will
save lives i love this analogy so much
and i have to say
one time i got invited to a ted talks
and it was about 10 years ago and i kind
of wandered in i'd never been in one
before and they gave me a ticket they
were like oh check it out and i i came
in and i sat down and
uh dr singer you were the first ted talk
i ever heard
and it really was like a punch in the
heart um and you used a similar analogy
of of the child on the street in china
people can can look that up if they want
to but it's it's a similar kind of
analogy about um
the
moral imperative to alleviate human
suffering but you've delivered this
analogy so many times but why why is it
i mean the
the question really is why don't people
see the correlation between the drowning
child
and the millions of children that go to
bed hungry every single night and are at
risk of dying from various diseases that
live below the poverty line over 700
million 800 million something like that
people live well below the poverty line
why are
why are we wired
to not see that is it because it
requires work to think it through is it
because
hey if they die
that no one can really put it upon us i
mean you must have been asked this
question um
half a million times
i have been asked quite often and i've
i've looked into the psychology that
relates to this and you know you use the
word uh as being wired
not to respond in some way and i think
that's accurate because
i think we evolved in very small
face-to-face societies
where we
would help people who we knew
and who were part of our group um
scientists think that we spent most of
our evolutionary early history as humans
in groups of maybe uh 100 to two hundred
so you would know everybody in that
group uh and and you would help them if
they were in need but your capacity to
help others outside that group would be
very limited um and in fact maybe the
groups around your own group's territory
would be hostile so
that would be a risky thing to do
so i think we've we've evolved to help
the the face-to-face
people and and to some extent my little
child in the pond story plays on that
because you see the child in front of
you even if you don't know that child
you see the child whereas i'm then
asking you to consider situations of
people who you can't see they're far
away you don't know who will be helped
even if
even if you use the internet as against
malaria foundation for example
does tell you where your donation is
going which villages they're
distributing nets in
but you still don't actually know which
child you're going to save because of
course
the children who who are under bed nets
aren't going to die and
maybe one or some of them would have
died but you don't know which so
um i think we're not psychologically
attuned to respond to
people who are not in front of us and
particularly people who we can't
identify
as individuals so i think it's a
psychological problem it's not really a
problem of reasoning most people when
they think about this
they don't say oh well
uh just because somebody's far away is
not a reason to care
that's a reason not to care about them
um but it's rather the emotional pull
isn't there and
so many people respond to these
emotional pulls they don't respond to
their thinking and reflection about
you know is this something really
important that i could save a child's
life um the cost to me is quite small
does that mean i ought to do it i think
when people do think about it that way
they tend to agree yes i should do it i
think you're absolutely right and and
you've talked a lot about the psychology
of giving and and even the evolution
of it the evolutionary sort of
backdrop of it and this idea that we're
sort of more geared towards
helping people who are
uh closer to us who look like us
um who we feel some kind of communion
with as opposed to people who aren't et
cetera et cetera that's why you know
when there's a disaster in the united
states we are as americans far more
likely to pour money into aid than if
there were a disaster say in haiti which
we feel like well it's
it's different than us it's not us
whatever the case may be
but i wonder if there's something else
to
which is related but somewhat distinct
which is
the sense of responsibility
where
i feel as though
i'm in a situation in which i am
responsible for this drowning child
because i am there
and it's almost like there's a burden a
weight that's placed up upon me
but i do think that there is something
to be said about here where people do
whether they can
express it or not
feel like
well i'm not responsible for that person
on the other side of the planet and
that really gets to the heart of the
morality of what you're trying to say
here is is
trying to
uh
convince people that they do
indeed have a responsibility to that
child on the other side of the planet
yeah i think that's that's really
important uh and the way i
presented the example i was trying to
make explicit that you're not
responsible for the child in the pond
you know that you're not the child's
parents
you know it's not as if the child's
babysitter said oh look could you take
care of this child for a moment i've got
to go to the bathroom uh you know it's
just a complete stranger and you clearly
have no responsibility for the child
being in the pond but but you're right
that there is a sense of i'm responsible
for people
in my neighborhood or the people i see
in front of me
i'm not sure what we can
do to get people to feel that
responsibility i
i
i i wrote a book a few years ago called
one world in which i tried to emphasize
that we are one world now that we are
interconnected in in many ways and that
there are many problems that we can't
possibly solve on our own climate change
is the classic example uh you know the
greenhouse gases that
we produce in the u.s or where i am now
in australia
are going to affect everyone in the
world and similarly the greenhouse gases
that they're going to produce are going
to affect everybody
so i think we need to encourage a sense
of global responsibility and
particularly when we're talking about
extreme poverty and if we're living in
one of those affluent countries like the
united states to feel that we only have
responsibilities to people in the united
states
really has a very bad effect that
your charity is directed to people who
are already
relatively well off even if you're
helping some of the poorest people in
the u.s
they are still well above the world
bank's extreme poverty line which is as
rain mentioned there
seven to 800 million people who are
below that line and virtually none of
them
are in the us
by the way i just want to say
that uh
reza has so many children that if i was
walking through a park and it was one of
his kids i would just keep on walking
because he's got so many he wouldn't
even notice that's true there he would
not like oh where's little
shipley aslan i i we haven't seen him in
a week
ryan at this point how many episodes do
you think we have done that have had
something to do with the climate crisis
climate crisis has been mentioned in at
least a quarter or third of our episodes
and that's why
this new startup ren
is kind of intriguing yes ren is a
startup that's making it easy for
everyone to make a meaningful difference
in the climate crisis right now they're
focused on monthly subscriptions where
you can calculate your carbon footprint
then offset it by supporting awesome
climate projects that plant trees
protect rainforests and remove co2 from
the sky so the goal is to unlock the
collective action of millions of
individuals to drive the systemic change
needed to end the climate crisis so this
is how it works you go to the ren
website and there you can calculate your
own personal carbon footprint based on
your lifestyle
and then you can offset it by funding
projects that plant trees protect
rainforests sequester co2 all that stuff
and it's really easy you it's very easy
to sign up for ren
it's just basically a way to do
something meaningful about the climate
crisis and i know that a lot of us are
feeling very
you know hopeless about it and you think
like well what could one individual do
except to recycle well this is something
that you can do
ren practices hyper transparency once
you sign up to make a monthly
contribution to offset your carbon
footprint you'll receive monthly updates
about the tree planting rainforest
protection and carbon removal projects
that you are funding you can even see
the exact coordinates of the trees you
planted
it's going to take all of us to end the
climate crisis do your part today by
signing up for ren go to ren
w-r-e-n dot c-o
slash milkshake sign up and they'll
plant 10 extra trees in your name that's
w-r-e-n
dot
c-o-slash milkshake start making a
difference thank you ren
milkshakers i hear people say that vpns
have a reputation for slowing down your
internet speed but you know what nord
vpn
doesn't because it's the fastest vpn in
the world i use it i do not have to
sacrifice internet speed for better
security with nordvpn my internet
traffic is routed through a secure
encrypted tunnel which protects my data
and privacy public wi-fi is notorious
for being a hotbed for hackers
so by using nordvpn on my phone laptop
and ipad this protects me from hackers
gives me peace of mind while traveling
plus
i can log into my netflix account yeah
you can actually access content from
over what 59 different countries all you
got to do is change your virtual
location with one click on nordvpn so
for instance i live in the us
but if i've got a nordvpn i could be
anywhere in the world virtually i can
access content from those regions that
means i can watch one of my absolute
favorite shows peaky blinders oh that's
silly and murphy so grab your exclusive
nordvpn deal by going to
nordvpn.com milkshake
or use the code milkshake to get a huge
discount off your nord vpn plan plus one
additional month for free plus a bonus
gift
it's completely risk-free with nord's
30-day money-back guarantee you'll also
get the bonus gift of nordvpn's brand
new
anti-malware software
threat protection there's a 30-day
money-back guarantee if nordvpn is not
for you so there is no risk whatsoever
so this goes to the the heart of uh your
work and and uh so much of your your
philosophy we've used this phrase a few
times now effective altruism
can you just
for our listeners give us sort of the
most basic definition of what we mean
when we say effective altruism
we've talked around a little bit yeah
sure well altruism i think most people
understand it's it's wanting to do good
to others um and
part of the problem with altruism there
are plenty of people who are altruistic
in various ways and you know a lot of
americans
give to to charity
so
that's great
but
very few of them really think hard about
am i giving to a charity that will give
me the best value
for the money i'm donating
um you know compare compare the
attitudes to let's say buying a new
phone or a new car or a new laptop
and people will check around and they'll
look at ratings and what people say and
they'll say
can i get you know what what's the best
i can get for what i can afford
and and that that makes sense and if if
they went out and got something and then
somebody said ah you could have got a
better one for less money than you paid
you feel a fool
but when people give to charity they
hardly ever do that they hardly ever say
is this the best charity that i could
given to the one that will do the most
good that will reduce suffering the most
say
with the amount of money that i can give
to charity
but effective altruism says that's what
you should be doing you should make sure
that what you're doing and it doesn't
have to be money by the way it could be
volunteering your time it could be a
range of things
just try to make sure that whatever
resources you have that you're going to
use altruistically you do the most good
that you can
with them
and unfortunately you no longer have to
spend hours and hours doing all that
research yourself
because as i mentioned
the life you can save curates a list of
effective charities if you
go there to the life you can save dot
org you can quickly find a selection of
charities you can look at what they're
doing they're all
independently verified as as effective
and you can donate to one of them this
goes to a quick follow-up question i
have some experience because i've worked
in the non-profit sector and in
philanthropy in haiti and i've seen
some egregious i use degree just twice
in two different contexts i'm not sure i
used it well he just learned the word to
the other day you need to finish the
sentence then then we can tell you
uh i saw egregious examples of wasteful
nonprofits in haiti and there's been
much written about it from both from the
united nations and
and red cross but two very large players
on the world stage that simply got
funding for certain projects that last a
certain amount of time and as soon as
that funding dries up they're gone
they're just gone so whatever they've
set into motion
all of a sudden they're just not there
we saw a school that was run by a large
large large large large non-profit
and these kids kept showing up every day
and there were no teachers
and we were like what the hell is going
on it's like oh
they
even though this has a billion dollar
endowment this non-profit they lost
their specific funding from whatever
foundation for the school and they just
pulled up and left they didn't tell the
community anything they just they just
left and the poor kids were showing up
to this empty shell of a school every
day it uh never ceases to piss me off
and that happened 10 years ago but
my question to you is what is
ineffective altruism well you just gave
an an egregious example of it i think
yes
nice that's
that's a uh
that's really poor i mean you really
need organizations that will follow
follow up and make sure that whatever
they've put into it is still working and
still doing what it should be doing so
that's that's definitely one kind of
example
but there are other things which which
sound like good ideas but when you
follow them through they they don't
really work
a few years ago there was a little craze
about
pumps that would pump water up for
people
by children playing on a kind of one of
those uh spinning devices that you
somehow see at playgrounds that kids
push around and they they spin around
and this sounded like a great idea hey
the kids get to play on something plus
the water comes up and the adults don't
have to operate the hand pump
sounds terrific a couple of hollywood
stars got involved in backing it
but uh when it was really followed
through some of these pumps that had
been play pumps as they were called had
been installed it turned out that the
kids got bored with them fairly fast
um
and went spinning around pumping up the
water so the adults had to push this
round thing around and around which is
actually harder work than just operating
a simple hand pump
and so it was basically you know a waste
of effort so um
innovations good ideas need to be tested
they need to be checked out in practice
um and that's what uh organizations that
are auditing these uh like give well i
like the life you can save uh there's a
few others um are really doing they're
they're going back there and they're
checking that things are really working
as expected and that the interventions
have the impact that there's a
scientific backing for saying yes this
is something that people need this is
what they want this is what the local
people
are requesting
and it does actually work in the long
run
element is a tasty electrolyte drink mix
with everything you need and nothing you
don't that means lots of salt
with no sugar you heard me
salt
in fact when i got my packet of uh
elements i was like oh it's one of these
like hydration mixes uh you know some
extra electrolyte wait a minute what is
this it's
it's salt like it what am i i'm not am i
gonna drink salt water pop it in it's
salty yeah it's a little bit salty but
it's like delicious salty it comes in
all kinds of crazy flavors and it
contains a science-backed electrolyte
ratio that's a thousand milligrams of
sodium 200 milligrams of potassium 60
milligrams of magnesium but with none of
the junk so you know i play a lot of
tennis i joined this little tennis club
ever since we moved out here i love it
and um i'm sweating like an ox out there
i put in a couple element lmnt
uh
capsules in my water bottle
yeah it's a little vague hint of salt so
it's a little bit getting used to
because so many of these you know
powders are so sweet you know
artificially sweet um but i felt
refreshed and nourished i had plenty of
energy i didn't feel dehydrated at the
end of the night and i kicked butt at
tennis element is so sure you will love
their product and come back for more
that they're offering you a free element
sample pack that's eight single serving
packets free
just cover the cost of shipping
five dollars for u.s customers get yours
at drink
lmnt.com milkshake
this deal is not available on their
regular website you must go to
drink
lmnt that's d-r-i-n-k-l-m-n-t
dot com slash milkshake element offers a
no questions asked refund try it totally
risk-free if you don't like it share it
with a salty friend and we'll give you
your money back no questions asked so
you got nothing to lose
there is also i guess a utilitarian
aspect to your idea of effective
altruism and you are you i think you've
described yourself quite proudly as a
utilitarian sure yeah yeah the idea of
this is that you know well you should do
the most good
that you can do and oftentimes
this is just a fact the
the most good that you can do involves
giving the most money that you can give
and again you've spoken at length about
this
um
but i have to say that that philosophy
has really started to fall out of favor
in the last
uh couple of years um it's hard
to look at people like for instance jeff
bezos
or
elon musk or just you know
fill in the blank with your douchebag
billionaire okay
uh
who
get lauded
jeff bezos gave away a billion dollars
last year and was lauded for that it's a
very utilitarian thing if it's you know
one percent of his income and he gave it
away and he made a ton of money and he
put a billion dollars out into the world
and let's assume that he put it out
there effectively we're not sure about
that but let's assume that he did
but a lot of people would say
yeah
but
you spent the last year destroying the
planet
destroying lives in order to make the
hundred billion dollars
that allowed you to give a billion
dollars away so far from being lauded
you should be condemned
for that and that
that view
tends to kind of be at odds a little bit
with um
you know what you're what you often talk
about about the sort of the utilitarian
framework for
effective altruism
i'll give you just a little personal
example of this my wife is a you know
she's a non-profit pioneer she created
kiva um 15 years ago i'm sure you're
familiar with with kiva the micro
lending platform
you know she did that um in 2004 2005
while she was getting her mba at
stanford and almost every one of her
co-workers
went on
to work at facebook
and google
and amazon and they are all
multi-multi-millionaires and let's
assume that they've given away
you know a couple of million dollars
whatever that's a lot of money it's
great
she
created
you know the the world's first
non-profit unicorn uh they they've given
i think a billion and a half dollars you
know in loans at this point
um and she made nothing for for years
and years and years
and so
has not really kind of is not somebody
who gives money to to charities really
you know it's just not it's just not
part of her the way that she thinks of
altruism
um
so in some sense you could look at you
know the facebook millionaires and say
well
if you're talking about utilitarianism
do the most good give the most money
that you can as often as you can
they're they're sort of morally superior
to
you know jessica who
founded an organization that does
literally pull people out of poverty but
who at the same time also
um you know has not been in financially
in a situation in which she's able to
give you know large amounts of money so
i guess all of this is just to say
how do you respond to people who who
talk about the fact that
more
isn't always
best
well i
think that more
is best if it doesn't come with other
costs
but of course
if it does come with costs if in order
to acquire the more
to give it away you have to harm a lot
of people or damage the environment or
damage the world then that's a negative
and when you do the sums in the end it
may come out that it was not more it may
come out that
jeff bezos has not done more than uh
jessica your wife uh that's what you
need to look at now you know it's pretty
complicated story to try to assess of
any specific billionaire whether what
they've done is good good on the whole
or bad on the whole and and how you do
that well can we can we just talk about
bezos then because that that seems like
a part so let's talk about jeff bezos
you know how he he made his hundreds of
billions of dollars and you know that he
has given away billions of dollars what
would your
um
your judgment be about say uh jeff bezos
well i still think it's complicated um
because you know he has made books
cheaper and more accessible i've bought
books from amazon because i can get them
quickly
i couldn't get them otherwise from where
i am
and i think spreading information and
spreading knowledge is a valuable thing
and of course amazon has done that not
only with books but with many other
items as well so uh it's still not it's
not clear-cut now certainly his workers
have not always been treated well um and
it's interesting to see that and in
bringing things you know cheaper and to
a broader audience he has
taken that away from
hundreds of thousands of
small business owners i mean this is the
thing about utilitarianism right is that
it's in in the calculations difficult
yeah very very difficult you know okay
so now i agree the calculations are very
difficult but you surely wouldn't want
to ignore these facts right you
yeah i mean
you you can't just look i i i'm prepared
to say that i prefer a tax system and a
structure in which nobody became a
billionaire in which the money instead
was taxed and then used to help people
on lower incomes or to protect the
environment or to do the many other
things that we need governments to do
so
yes in that sense
i
am opposed to billionaires but
with any individual billionaire of
course it's a more complicated story and
we need to know both what they are doing
what are they giving away um
so
my impression of jeff bezos's
philanthropy is it's not actually as
effective um as say what uh what bill
gates has done in setting up the gates
foundation which has saved millions of
lives
through
working against diseases of various
kinds
one of the good things that i think has
happened from jeff bezos is that
his former wife mackenzie scott has got
a substantial part of the money he made
and
she's giving it away to more effective
charities so just uh saw some of the
charities that she's giving it to and
some of them are on
the uh life you can saves list let me
just say that uh mackenzie bezos has
given away 20
of her wealth which was almost 50
billion dollars
and jeff bezos has only given away 1
of his 200
billion dollars
so
doesn't it at the end of the day kind of
come down to percentages really well
that's certainly a very relevant figure
yes absolutely and um
and jeff bezos you know has given away
an amount that he would not notice
really in terms of in terms of his
wealth uh whereas um mckenzie visa says
has has not done that and she's given
away a well a more noticeable amount i
guess he's still got plenty but i'm sure
she's going to continue to give to give
more away so i think that's very
relevant and that is after all a
utilitarian point to say that look if if
you've got the capacity to give away
200 billion or let's let's be generous
to him and say 199 billion so that he
can still have a billion to play around
with and lively
yeah so you know if you've got the
capacity to give away 199 billion and
you only give away one or two billion uh
you're not doing anything like the most
good you can do
so that's relevant and it's people like
like gates and and warren buffett for
example who has given to the gates
foundation and has said he wants to give
away most of his fortune before he dies
um i think they're people who are doing
better on that scale again you know it's
an open question as to
whether they did harm to acquire that
money but in terms of having the money
um i think they're doing
they're doing much better because
they're giving away a larger percentage
and they're giving it
in
ways that appear to be highly effective
yeah i mean
bezos is easy because it's very simple i
think for people to understand
the harm
that he has done in order to to do the
good that he has done
and so it's like the perfect
utilitarian philosophical argument in a
freshman college class you know
um
but you you did mention this like i mean
is it possible to even consider the idea
that it doesn't matter whether you're
warren buffett or bill gates
that
there is no
means there is no moral means of
accumulating that kind of wealth
so
great that warren buffett is giving it
all away
but it's very difficult not to recognize
the harm
or even maybe not necessarily that he
himself did but the
the the advantage that he took
of a broken system
right
or an unethical
path that he took
in order to then
be able to get to the place where he
could do the most good possible so i
guess
you know
well i mean look there's a reason why
utilitarianism has fallen out of favor
in some ways except you know in the
world i challenge that by the way i
don't think it has fallen out of favor
but yeah um so you know we're talking
worldwide here not just the united
states united states because of its
talk about rights all the time and the
the rights tradition has never been a
place where there's been a lot of
utilitarian thinking but if you look at
it
across the world i think there is a lot
more utilitarian thinking i think in
fact the pandemic showed that
even in the united states because
despite all the talk about individual
rights when it came down to an emergency
people accepted
very severe restrictions on their
freedom of movement for example in
lockdowns
for the sake of the greater good
and i think that showed to many people
that uh
really
rights are not fundamental but
doing good making people better off
avoiding a lot of suffering and misery
and premature death
is something that people are prepared to
give up rights in order to have
but uh but but that's a little bit of a
digression i just wanted to come back to
warren buffett and his situation because
uh
so buffett has spoken openly
about the unfairness of the tax system
in the united states he's pointed out
that he pays a lower rate of tax on his
income than his secretary does um and
he's also called for a call called for
the restoration of estate taxes
so-called death duties um
because he thinks that that's a fair way
to redistribute income so it's not as if
buffett is you know just saying hey you
know yes this is a great system that
i've that has enabled me to make uh many
billions of dollars um he's calling for
change and of course it you know it has
an impact when somebody like him does
that
so you know what what was he supposed to
do given that he had this gift for
picking companies that you know he could
invest in and make a lot of money uh
i think
he tried to change the system
um
yes you could say in a way he's taken
advantage of the fact that it hasn't
changed but he's also using the wealth
he's accumulated to do good things and
yes and at least there's that and but it
does remind me a little bit about when
when president obama
said hey i think that you guys should um
pass a law to keep me from being able to
drone whoever the hell i want to drone
in the meantime i'm going to drone
whoever the hell i want to drone
so
i i hear it that's very true that that
i'm really happy that at the end of his
very long very successful very
profitable life warren buffett has said
uh maybe
the system that i used to become a
billionaire was unethical and the rest
of you should do something about it but
in the meantime i'm going to give my
money away
i'm not making it simplistic it's a very
complicated you you'd mentioned the
death tax uh before and uh dr singer i
just wanted to say i had i did an
interview with elon musk several years
ago where i famously offered him a bite
of my chicken sandwich in exchange for a
tesla
um which didn't quite work out but
he was talking very much about the death
tax because that that's a perfect way to
tax billionaires because essentially
you're just taking away from their
children that haven't done anything
anyway exactly it's a little bit
different than someone who's who is a
you know an income generating profit
maker entrepreneur business builder and
if you tax them too much and stop them
from you know that's what a lot of
capitalists would argue
it's it's a little different so that is
um but here i have a i want to change
gears a little bit i want to change
direction a little bit so i'm going to
put on a little bit of a different hat
so both reza and i come from a religious
background and you are a famous uh
atheist i don't wanna get into you know
whether there's god or not that's a kind
of boring argument but help me to
understand this
utilitarianism
and uh from
utilitarianism effective altruism
is what one could call a kind of a
secular
morality it really is an ethics of
hey
here i am
a human being on this planet
i should do what's right and good and
what's right and good is to alleviate
suffering of others and let's do that in
a in the most effective way possible
so from a religious perspective
i'm a member of the baha'i faith so
baha'is embrace all the different
religious traditions we were
interviewing these monks a few weeks
back these buddhist monks and they
talked about meditating every day on the
suffering of others
so that as you in meditation find peace
in yourself through the process of
meditation you're also gaining
compassion for others and the suffering
of others and then you work towards
alleviating the suffering of others so
they're buddhists
in the bible
it's just chock-a-block with jesus
helping the poor one of the five pillars
of islam is helping the poor
now whether christians buddhists and
muslims actually do this
is a question whether they do it
effectively is another question
we know that of um
the 80 of americans that give to
non-profits 40 percent of that giving is
church based we're not sure if
church-based giving is really the most
effective way to
relieve the suffering of others but
on a larger point help me help me
understand from an atheist perspective
from a secular humanist perspective
if i'm a consciousness on this planet
and i'm looking around
and there's
um the only purpose i find is a purpose
that i create uh of myself because i'm
just in a material universe and there's
a lot of molecules bouncing around and
the material world and energy and mass
and matter has always existed and always
will for whatever reason
why
dr singer
why
is there or should there be an
imperative toward good where does that
moral imperative
come from
if not some kind of like
divine source that leads one to greater
empathy compassion
giving and altruism
because because part of me goes i'm
sorry i'm being a little long-winded but
because part of me goes and i'm really
trying to honestly understand this and i
would love your insight and we have a
lot of atheist and agnostic uh listeners
um
wouldn't my
without anything higher than uh atoms
and molecules wouldn't it just simply be
life simply be about pleasuring myself
and the people that i love that are
close to me and living in maximum
comfort
why care about children in bangladesh
from this uh ethical perspective that
you have spent your life
fighting for well ultimately i think
it comes from our ability to
understand
what
it is like to be other people and for
that matter to be non-human animals as
well
in situations
where they are suffering
and if we know our own suffering or we
know the suffering of those close to us
there's then i think a
connection that our ability to to reason
makes certainly supported by our ability
to to empathize and as i said earlier i
think that comes from
our evolution in small-scale societies
but then our reason
tells us that these are other people
they may look different from us they may
be far away from us
but they are experiencing things that i
we know about when when we are in
situations of suffering or maybe things
much worse
and
those are things that are bad that we
recognize as bad that we want to avoid
ourselves
and because we're
being capable of reasoning we can take a
more impartial point of view
i sometimes use the metaphor take the
point of view of the universe but of
course i know the universe doesn't
really have a point of view as you said
it's
uh it's it's material things adam's
bouncing around but but just as a
metaphor we can rise above our own
personal situation we can look at things
from a broader perspective and we can
say oh you know i think it's bad that i
suffer i think it's bad that my children
or others i love suffer um and really
these are other people these are other
beings capable of suffering they have
their own children they have their own
griefs
those are just as bad
from that broader point of view
and
if i
don't think about that if i just ignore
that
there's something there's something
wrong with my actions i mean i would not
want them to ignore
my suffering if they were in a similar
situation and able to help and
so i shouldn't really be ignoring their
suffering either so it's a golden golden
rule essentially i think something like
the golden rule yeah um and you know
that's a tradition that exists uh in
various places i think that's
something that comes to us through our
reason i mean the thinkers in different
cultures have
come to something like the golden rule
so um yeah i think that's that's a
part of our capacity to reason in this
kind of impartial way that gives our
eyes to the insight
into the golden rule well here we come
to the the question of this show what do
we owe
each other what do we owe one another
um
i mean we you know we've talked about
this in in various ways about how to to
give
the why of it i think is really
interesting and important but
fundamentally you know when we're
talking about the responsibility that we
have to our fellow humans
and
how we determine
you know
what the worth of a human life is how we
create the moral balance between
um what we spend on ourselves and what
we spend on others and and where we draw
the line where we where we finally
decide what is enough you know what how
much is enough should i
should i
give you know everything that i have
because that's the moral thing to do if
i'm trying to do the most that i
possibly can or even what does it mean
to just be a good person to live a good
life and how do we
help one another get there
all of these sort of questions are
wrapped up you know in this question of
what do we owe
each other um
and of course this is a a philosophical
question that you've spent
most of your adult life pondering how
would you how would you answer that
question what what do we owe each other
i think there's both a kind of
theoretical answer to that and a
practical answer and i'd like to
distinguish them the theoretical answer
is
i think we owe them
everything that will do them more good
than it will do us harm
so that's
a a very extreme demand although
incidentally uh reign as you talked
about jesus it's not more extreme than
jesus you know she told the rich man to
sell everything he has and give to the
poor and i don't see very many
christians actually doing that but um
no uh you know that's i but i agree in a
way with uh with that well not sell
everything you have because you need to
keep enough so that you yourself won't
become dependent on charity for others
but um beyond that you know that would
be the ideal that would be the
theoretical limit
but
you know in practice i also recognize
that human nature generally speaking
isn't up to that i mean there are some
saints um there's a wonderful book by
larissa mcfarland called strangers
drowning which um yeah and i think that
title actually relates to the the child
in the pond example that i gave but she
talks about people who are incredibly
saintly in in helping people and go a
very long way well even i would say i'm
sorry to interrupt but problematically
saintly where they they give to the
point so it's the opposite of what you
had just said they give to the point
where it does damage themselves some of
the some of them do yes that's true um
but uh you know i recognize that very
there are very few people like that and
for most of us that's too demanding and
ethic we can't really do it and and i
when i say most of us i am actually
including myself i mean i have not given
away to that point where if i gave away
any more i would harm myself more than
i'm benefiting others
i do
you know live a more comfortable life
than that would suggest and i
take more care for my children and
grandchildren than that would suggest
too but um i think in practice if we
come to the practical answer
we
will
do best we will get people to act on
this kind of standard not if we tell
them that they have to give away
uh to the
to the limit of of
how much good they can do
but
to a point where they can
help people significantly help others
significantly at what is just clearly a
much lower cost to themselves
and i think that's not too difficult the
standard
and for some people will depend on what
income you are for some people it may
mean the traditional tithe the 10 of
your income for some people who are at a
lower level they can't afford that
either and it in in the book the life
you can save i do have at the end a kind
of a scale of giving which starts at
quite small one or two percent for
people on low incomes and goes up to uh
giving away a third of your income for
people who are very wealthy um with all
kinds of gradations in between so i
think that's uh you know that that's
kind of estimate of what's
a more practical level that you can say
to people this won't really
do you any harm in fact given that you
will get some satisfaction and meaning
in your life by knowing that you are
doing something to help people much less
well off than you are um it may actually
on balance do you more good than it does
harm
but um in any case it will do others a
lot of good and if we
were all to give at that level we really
would have a world in which we didn't
have that seven or eight hundred million
people living in extreme poverty we
would easily raise enough to lift them
above that line um and to do a lot of
other good things as well
so in a way it shouldn't be too
difficult
for us to to deal with with extreme
poverty in the world and to help people
at the lowest level uh without making
great sacrifices and that's really what
uh
i'm arguing for in the life you can save
and what the the charity the life you
can say which
arose from that book is trying to
achieve
um beautifully said
and i highly recommend this book folks
and
it makes it feel
possible
and you have been doing this work for
decades and i thank you for your work in
the perspectives
of
tens of hundreds of thousands of people
that you've shifted and it really feel
like we can save lives and if we
uh
stop making some a couple of minor
thinking errors um
so thank you for that work but i do have
a favor to ask of you dr singer please
go ahead can you please make a a thunder
and lightning sound effect
a thunder and lightning sound effect out
of your mouth
pretend you're seven yeah
i don't know whether i can do it and
lightning i don't think makes the sound
does it it's okay
very very good i don't know very good
very musically i've never i've never you
know you've had the benefit of being on
stage and you have to make strange
noises i guess i've never really done
that apart from
things like ted talks your sound effect
was
the worst it sounded like a kangaroo
farting
and i'm really sorry that i asked you
but you bravely set forth and for that i
thank you and now we're into the
lightning round dr singer we're going to
ask you a handful of questions profound
questions some silly questions and we
just want your first response the first
thing that comes into your mind that
comes into your heart can we replay uh
dr singer's sound effect right here
thank you
when do you feel most connected with the
universe
when i wake up
if you could live during any historical
moment which one would it be i would
live now i think this is a really
exciting and important time to be living
in
what is something that very very few
people know about you that you can share
with us right now
they probably don't know that my
grandfather was part of sigmund freud's
wednesday circle and that he actually
co-authored a paper with sigmund freud
wow i did not know that
cool
my grandfather was a farmer my
grandfather was an actor
he like rain made sounds with his mouth
what is something that a lot of people
like but you hate
i'm a bit stuck on this one um you know
maybe maybe maybe burgers right well
what about impossible burgers oh the the
substance okay but i hate the fact that
these burgers are served in these soft
white rolls i don't know why they don't
serve burgers in something a little more
decent and
chewy than those things
if you could have lunch with any author
past present who would it be and why
what would you talk about
oh um
i have uh recently edited a new edition
of a book called the golden ass which
was written by apollos in the second
century so about 180
of the present era
and he was a seems to have been a
fascinating person we don't know a lot
about him but he wrote this very funny
book
and rather sexy bawdy book as well i
should say
which is also about an ass a donkey uh
or really a person who is transformed
into a donkey and it gives you a
wonderful empathy with the donkey and
with all the horrible things that are
done to the emp to the donkey in the
second century of the roman empire
so i would really love to have lunch
with him learn more about his life which
is just not known
and um what it is that made him write
this book so far in advance of his time
that he's really empathetic to animals
in an era when generally people were not
very empathetic to animals i have a
donkey i own a donkey and his name is
chili beans her name is chili beans
and donkeys are wonderful if anyone's
looking for a pet and they're thinking
outside the box donkeys are smart loyal
and so huggable
um
i i can't tell you how much i love chili
beans the donkey and
this has increased my empathy to the
point
with which you were talking about
hamburgers earlier i would never eat
a donkey burger good well you should you
should read
my edition of the golden s i think
you'll you'll enjoy it
it's on my to-do list thank you fun fact
the golden ass is my nickname for rain i
didn't i didn't even know that
peter singer what is the one book that
you would say changed your life
not including the golden ass oh
um
i would say ruth harrison's animal
machines which is a book that probably
none of your listeners viewers have have
read um because it's uh you know a small
publisher when i first started thinking
about the treatment of animals back in
1970 it was the only book written about
factory farming which was already
developing
and it had a very powerful
impact on me i think it made me stop
eating factory farmed animals and of
course eventually move towards being
not eating animals at all
and you know that was really important
to me because
once
you make an ethical decision that
affects what you eat that affects you
every day of your life um then you know
you really get a sense of the power of
ethics to change lives um and you know
that led me to write animal liberation
which i know has changed many more lives
uh so
ruth harrison's animal machines had a
huge life-changing effect on me dr peter
singer truly thank you for taking time
out of your impossibly busy schedule to
meet with us
uh your book is transformative the work
that you've done i truly thank you from
the bottom of my heart you have
in your life reduced the suffering
of millions of people through your
books through your speaking through your
work
thank you for that and thanks for
joining us on metaphysical milkshake
thank you i really appreciate the
opportunity to join you the life you can
save uh i read this 10 years ago and
it's out in a brand new edition now and
of course the organization is the life
you can save is it.org yes it's dot org
yeah dot org and uh and there it's
really it's fantastic like if you have a
question about well who should i give
money to
uh this this website is excellent tells
you exactly the most effective charities
in the world doing the the best work for
the most uh good
well it's not every day you get to
interview
you know someone of the stature of a
peter singer like i mean i have a clear
memory i'm not a young man
i have a clear memory
of being a freshman
in ethics
101
and reading animal liberation and being
like i've never
even considered
any of this that was that was kind of a
that was a big deal
you know it was a big deal and uh
something we forgot to mention in the
intro was
uh in looking at his research he
received there's a billionaire and yet
another billionaire he's [ __ ]
billionaires jesus already
bergruin
bergruin is a german yeah
and he won he won the pride the bergeron
prize for philosophy and culture and a
one million dollar award
for that and guess what
he gave away the million dollars all the
way he gave it all away i think it would
have been awesome if he was like thank
you i'm buying your rolls
i'm gonna buy crypto
i'm gonna use it to get as much crypto
as i possibly can i feel like we could
have had this conversation much much
longer but it would have probably bored
the hell out of the audience but
i i do think
i'm i'm not satisfied
with
the utilitarian the sort of rank dry
utilitarian aspect of
some of his philosophy you know again
like i the bezos thing is perfect like i
it's very easy to [ __ ] on besos
but he can't do it
right he also really enjoys it when you
do yeah yeah that's another story that's
anyways because
fundamentally if you are a pure
utilitarian
and if you
you know com subscribe wholly to
effective altruism the way that he has
uh
you know developed it
then bezos is a hero
then it doesn't really matter
how
he made
his billions it makes no difference make
as much money as possible
so that you could give as much money as
possible away
and
i don't know
if that
works as well
anymore you know what i mean there's
something
besos
can't
erase
the bad that he has done in this world
no matter how much money he gives away i
don't think he can erase it well but for
so many people reza and we were talking
about this earlier um just on the phone
like for a lot of people they would say
[ __ ] you man
oh i'm sorry is creating
14 million jobs
uh really such a bad thing look at all
the people paying their mortgages
because amazon exists
thank you very much why don't you tell
it to all of them well certainly not not
the people in the warehouses that's for
sure but yes i hear you i hear you
so you know
there's something to be said for that
and also it's isn't it just simply alt
utilitarianism just comes down to a
cost-benefit analysis like if you did
x amount uh categorical um
damage to the planet and to the
into humanity into the working place uh
to the workers and then you contrast
that with x number of billions given and
it supersedes the damage you did then it
is a net positive so
um but i agree with you i think it's i
think it's flawed because i think
you know listen
you know me at heart i'm a really i'm a
softy i'm kind of a hippie pansy baha'i
and i think it all comes down to um
and we didn't talk about compassion but
i just think about
the amount of compassion we have when
someone we love is sick is so can be so
overwhelming
even a pet that we have is sick i know
people and i've experienced it myself
they have a sick dog or a dead dog
and they're they're they're weeping to
such an extent
um
that it's almost unfathomable grief
and yet we read in the newspaper about a
train tipping over in pakistan and 600
people died think about their families
like
and i know this sounds really like um
simply uh philosophical but i truly
believe that
where
we need humanity to go
is to
um hyper increase that
sensitivity to compassion that
compassion is like a muscle and it can
be worked out and we need to exercise it
and stretch it and breathe into it and
practice it and bring it into our daily
meditation our daily thought when we see
a homeless person we see a home a poor
person when we read about events in the
news um we have been able to do this
with the war in the ukraine
we have been able to do this culturally
with the war in the ukraine this is a
war it's in a western country which is
important only in as much as
people watching the war on the tvs go
wow they're living in an apartment
building just like mine and walking to a
grocery store just like mine and now
buying the same skin color as i do yeah
and they say same skin color now bombs
have hit that grocery store and that our
apartment building and that parking
garage and killed all these people with
white skin and i so relate to that and i
feel for and also the
people of the ukraine have shown
themselves to be
tenacious fighters and quite courageous
at the same time so we have increased
our compassion let us then come increase
that same compassion to the war in yemen
where they don't live in apartment
buildings or have grocery stores like
ours and they don't have the same skin
color and to increase our compassion to
a deeper and deeper level and if if
seven and a half billion people are
actively practicing
compassion to this level
we will of necessity
heal the income inequality and the
poverty that exists on planet earth and
it sounds i almost hate myself for
saying that because it's so simplistic
and it's so hippy dippy airy fairy
please set me right reza well i i won't
set you right but i will throw a wrench
in in the whole thing and this again
comes to
phillis you know i'm not about to have a
philosophical argument with the
philosopher but now that he's no longer
on the line oh yeah let's skewer him
yeah uh now that he can't respond um
the problem again with utilitarianism
is that
it's a it's so theoretical
it it seems to make sense but it because
it's so theoretical so
here's here's a an uncomfortable fact
that i am
willing to admit
and that i would bet that a lot of
people
would be willing to admit or maybe not
exactly you know willing but would admit
let's use the
drowned kid analogy okay
if i walk into a park and i see a a kid
drowning yeah of course i'm gonna jump
in there who cares about my suit i'm
gonna jump in there and i'm gonna save
that kid
if i walk into a park
and i see two kids drowning one of them
is my kid and one of them is someone
else's kid
it's not even an issue i'm gonna save my
kid
if i walk into a park
and i see two ponds one in which my kid
is drowning and the other in which a
hundred kids are drowning
guess who i'm saving
i would like to say
as a utilitarian
that obviously 100 lives
super sees one life
the very core of utilitarianism the most
good
for the most people
but
i would
i would
suffer
the deaths
of i don't know how many people
that i didn't know
in order to save the life of one of my
children
and [ __ ] utilitarianism
i'm
i'm not
exactly happy like morally
satisfied with that part of myself but i
have come to terms with it
and so
in a very real way i'll give you you
know that's i'm giving you a theoretical
example let me give you a real example
so i live in a very i live in los
angeles
terrible school district
in california the 49th worst
public school system
in all of the 50 united states
oh nice
and
i could have my kids go to a shitty
public school there's one not far from
me and get a shitty education and suffer
the consequences of that
and
then use my money to pay for
a girl in haiti to go to school you
could you could educate 100 girls in
haiti instead
i send my my three school-aged kids
to an expensive school
and the money that i use for that school
i i could
i could probably
educate every haitian girl
in haiti
uh yep i'm exaggerating but you know
what i'm saying put the two choices in
front of me put the two choices in front
of me
and i think of myself as a moral person
i give a lot of money and time and
resources away
i try my hardest to make the world
better but put those two choices in
front of me and i'm always going to
choose my children so i don't know what
to i don't know what to do about that i
don't know what to say about that i
don't know if that's a that says
something about me or about
utilitarianism or i don't know but it's
just
that's a fact that i can't get get
around uh i don't know what to say about
that i think i'm in the same boat i
don't know that it's such a bad thing um
there's more to be uncovered but i do
think that it all boils down to pee wee
herman
at the end of peewee's big adventure
there's a pet store fire
you remember the pet store fire scene
yes
and he goes in and he saves all the pets
pee-wee hates snakes
at risk of life and limb pee-wee herman
goes into the mofo in pet store
saves the snakes risking life and limb
and that's what it's all about folks
there you go
once again my co-host rayne wilson
has taken an enormously complex problem
and whittled it down to pee wee levels
thank you everyone one of the great
films of all time and ladies and
gentlemen thank you for listening to
metaphysical milkshake we would love to
hear from you follow us on the social
medias
and uh also leave us a good review on
apple podcast will you along with your
life's big question
and we would love to bring you on the
show and talk to you sometime what do
you say as a reminder
if you rate and review us on apple
podcasts all you got to do is take a
screenshot of it send us an email at
metaphysical
cast media.com metaphysical cast
media.com with that little screen grab
and you know what we're gonna send you a
free copy of the life you can save the
first 20 people to do that get a free
copy of the life you can save
also the audiobook is available for free
for all metaphysical milkshake listeners
there is a link in the notes on the
podcast download it now
thank you but don't ever say we don't
give you anything metaphysical milkshake
is executive produced by rayne wilson
reza aslan and colin thompson it is
produced by safa samazadeh yazd harris
lane mick dimaria hashem self and dj
lubel
cast media is the production and
distribution partner original music by
jeff tang
that could for example give them the
capital to start uh a small business and
there are some other charities that the
law or a podcast they could start their
own podcast even a podcast maybe yes if
as long as they have an internet
connection we need we need more of those
for the world so definitely yeah right
however yeah
right critical shortage of podcasts
where podcasts starved
maybe it's the milkshakes that you that
they need right that you're talking
about in your podcast that people need
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you